un record risque de tomber à la piscine
municipale de saint-ciirlécole le
dimanche 22 mai andyabrera Avilla un
apnéis de 45 ans d'origine cubaine va
tenter de parcourir la plus grande
distance possible en appné pendant 6h
pour cela le sportif devra effacer le
record de Pascal massé le français
effectué 9,3 km le 7 février dernier
pour le battre Andi s'entraîne au
minimum deux fois par semaine depuis 3
mois c'est un effortz intense les plus
dur les plus difficile c'est la gestion
de l'effort par rapport au
la dernière fois qu'on fait 6h je
beaucoup de cramp malgré le fait que je
m'hydrate tous les 30 minutes je
m'arrête pour une minute j'essie de
boire hydrater avec des l'eau sucré de
l'eau et des sels minéraux aussi un
record pour la bonne cause chaque
longueur effectuée permettra de récolter
1 € pour financer un exosquelette pour
aider Luna une enfant de 10 ans victime
d'une infirmité motrice cérébrale la
combinaison pourrait lui permettre de se
déplacer il y a une combinaison qui
coûte 6000 € n pas rembé pour la
sécurité sociale et cette combinaation
permet aux handicapés de améliorer leur
motricité donc Luna c'est mon élève
c'est une copine c'est quelquun de
magnifique donc c'est battre le record
des des Pascal mass mais pas uniquement
pour n'importe quoi c'est pour une cause
c'est les enfantc cur pendant ces
séances d'entraînement dabr VI a réussi
à parcourir la même distance que le
précédent record en seulement 3h 13
minutes